[Music]
gigi hadid
Megan Marco a Blake Lively and more hey
guys it is the season for coziness am i
right some of our favorite starlets are
slaying their winter weather style with
fabulous coats and jackets galore and
I've got all the fun details it's
literally the greatest first up GG's
shining bright in this faux fur
mustard-colored coat it's by DRA and
retails for one hundred and seventy six
dollars the 22 year old makes it look
effortlessly cool adding an H&M
turtleneck that costs just under 60
bucks and check out the kick she paired
the look a limited edition timberland
boots that retail for nine hundred and
thirty three bucks cozy casual and cute
check check check
it's incredible makes everything feel
like home next Rihanna she opted for
this oversized bomber jacket it's by vet
Lana and cost just over two grand but
get this
it's reversible it's like guys the limit
RiRi took comfy to a whole new level
rocky knees Navy sweat pants by Palace
skateboards with a look for around 150
bucks she added glamour by mixing in the
spring 2018 Jimmy Choo boots and
finished off the outfit with a pair of
Andie wolf cat eye sunglasses they
retail for three hundred and fifty
dollars Megan Marco went for a classic
winter white decode when she and Prince
Harry announced their engagement at
Versailles her she coaches byline the
label and retails for about six hundred
and twenty six dollars 36 year old
styled her outerwear with the suede
pumps by aqua Zara
they cost six hundred and ninety five
bucks and we love that she opted for the
Bridal white jacket it was the first
time she showed off her priceless
kleavon Company engagement ring which
features stones from Princess Diana's a
personal collection it's so important to
me to to know that she's a part of this
with us and finally a Blake Lively
proving she's the ultimate fashionista
Blake paired her denim dress with this
burgundy Bottega Veneta trench coat and
because it's made of deer it costs
almost $8,000 Blake made her look even
more fun
for these funky multicolored christian
louboutin boots worth 1295 bucks
I like to play which cosy and wintry
look would you wear to stay warm this
season let's talk all things fashion
over on Twitter and have a very happy
holiday season see you next year
[Music]